hey youtubers its charlie this is gonna
be my Doctor Who under the lake video I
actually did not know this is gonna be a
two-parter going into it so I feel like
the twist at the end like the twist
ending was a great setup for the next
episode it'll be interesting to compare
how well this two-parter stacks up
against the first two episodes against
the premiere two-parter overall it was a
great episode I feel like the level of
complexity like the narrative complexity
was a lot greater so you might not want
to show a first-time Doctor Who watcher
this episode first but I feel like for
longtime Doctor Who fans it's a little
bit more rewarding just because the
setup in the story are that much more
fascinating let's dig in though careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet a new round of the Doctor
Who giveaway starts now all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video it's just a $20
Amazon gift card so here we go starting
with top five moments number five the
TARDIS is afraid of ghosts it even
sounds the cloister bell to get the
doctor out if you don't remember what
it's all about the cloister bell is kind
of like the TARDIS says ultimate warning
light it just it goes off flashing
telling the doctor to get to battle
stations the first time it showed up was
actually when the fourth doctor
regenerated in lakopolous into the fifth
doctor that was actually a big master
episode but I think it's actually been a
while since we've seen the doctor talked
to the TARDIS in that way like what's
wrong what's going on like talk talking
to it as if it's a person it kind of is
a person the thing here is is that it
has something to do with the
electromagnetism that the ghost is
giving off it's not the ghosts
themselves that the TARDIS is afraid of
I think it's just afraid of something
that they haven't explained yet so we'll
find out about in the second episode the
doctors temporary explanation is that
the TARDIS is afraid of the ghosts
because they flaunt the natural order of
the universe they're unnatural you live
and you're supposed to die which is kind
of funny given the conceit of
regeneration on the number for the
underwater miners know all about the
doctor and all about unit and some of
them even fangirl on it just a little
bit I actually kind of like this because
you know when they meet the doctor
they're like oh my god we know all about
you they didn't have to waste a whole
bunch of time with scenes where the
doctor explains who he is who Time Lords
are how he regenerates like how it all
works one of them even said he wants to
join unit even though it feels like he
doesn't have the right stuff in the way
the doctor treats the deaf crew member
is really nice to oh course I know how
to speak sign language
you're the most clever person here
whenever I'm not around I can't remember
the last time I saw a Doctor Who episode
that made clever
use of a character with a disability
like that before the weirdest vibe I got
from her though is that she didn't want
this character she didn't want him to go
inside the spacecraft although it was
okay for everyone else despite how
dangerous it was but she just seems like
a selfless character in general like
she's the first person to say no I'll
stay behind and deal with this you could
all leave but you know obviously the
crew decides together they're going to
stay and speaking of which I feel like
this is set up for a reveal in the
second part of the episode because for
some reason the ghost left him alone so
either the twist is is that he's already
a ghost or he's the alien that's dead
locked inside that case somehow he is
tied to the people they're looking for I
feel like he's part of the mystery which
means by default this deaf crew member
might know something that she's not
telling everyone else you might know
something about him that she hasn't
revealed yet Pritchard here the mining
executive actually kind of reminded me
of Carter Burke from aliens the slimy
corporate character that's mostly
interested with profit ends up getting
himself killed out of his own
selfishness on the number three the
writing is an ear worm that song that
you can't get out of your head this is a
joke about every terrible song that you
just you hear once and you can never
forget even after you're dead you keep
repeating it but I'm wondering if this
electromagnetic signal that these
numbers are representing is part of the
reason why the TARDIS can't translate it
the doctor is still able to figure it
out I mean they trace this signal back
to that stasis pod which actually looks
like it's beaming a distress signal back
to where it came from and part of the
mystery is that it's using these ghosts
to boost the signal and maybe you
recognized it but when he was solving
the mystery he has that line I want to
kiss it to death like he gets really
excited that's actually directly out of
the first series night trailer that they
posted on the number two the doctor gets
separated from Clara in the only way to
fix the problem is to go back in time to
win it all started sorry Clara TARDIS is
afraid he ghosts can't just beam over to
the other side leaving Clara behind is
now like a theme for Capaldi's doctor
don't worry Clara I'll be back for you
I'll totally save you just just chill
out for a sec we're gonna go back in
time how do you do that extremely well
it's really great setup for the next
part because you're like oh my god
Clara's left behind is she gonna die
will she make it will the doctor be able
to save her which perfectly dovetails
into my number one WTF moment it turns
out that the doctor dies in the past
there's a new ghost
Clara's eyes getting really really wide
kind of tell
after reveal but still it looks amazing
Capaldi with his eyes blacked out like
the other ghosts what if the doctor dead
locked himself in that box so let's see
if we can follow this the doctor went
back in the past and the twist is is
that something happened that killed him
and he winds up being a ghost this whole
time but obviously in the teaser for the
next episode we see him going back in
time to before the dam burst and we see
Clark communicating with him so the
version of the doctor that she'll be
talking to in the next episode
will be from a different time I like the
way they're playing with time-travel in
the narrative in this it's a little more
rewarding for a longtime Doctor Who
viewers which is why I think it might be
confusing for people that have never
watched it before but just some really
important plot setup you need to
remember for next week is is that the
Deaf crew member here has some weird
connection to this character here who
the ghosts have some weird connection to
the biggest twist I feel like is gonna
be the reveal of what's inside that
stasis pod I feel like it's gonna be
something that we've seen in this
episode let me know in the comments
though what was your favorite moment
from this episode who do you think is
inside that box and what do you think
that this character's connection is to
all this I feel like it's gonna end up
being a great episode that just doesn't
invoke a lot of classic who like if
you're a big fan of Doctor Who
referencing classic Who and invoking
some of those storylines and tropes then
the premiere is gonna be a stronger
episode for that kind of stuff this new
episode will just end up being a really
great two-hour Doctor Who story on its
own having nothing to do with classic
ooh just to talk about classic ooh
references and easter eggs the biggest
one really I thought was the cloyster
belt that the TARDIS sounded but also
the idea that the doctor is a Shirley
Bassey fangirl is kind of funny I don't
think that Shirley Bassey ever actually
starred in Doctor Who I think I think
that that was just an offhanded
reference the alien here that was a
ghost
was a tu voli that's actually been in a
Doctor Who episode before there were
tavola in the god complex and it's
actually the first time in series 9 that
psychic paper shows up Clara has
mentioned working with the doctor on his
apologies that's kind of been a running
theme between the two of them like I'll
help you deal with your people skills
but I know it was also kind of like a
running joke during series 8 Clara
pretending to be the doctor like the
Time Lord that almost was he actually in
this episode has that nice line where he
says you know it's like a whole big
dimension in here there's only room for
one me as funny as that is that's really
just the doctor saying you know please
don't die
don't go native don't turn it into a
ghost you can't regenerate like me
that's actually really interesting idea
to remember we saw the ghosts in the
mess hall then we saw his body floating
by outside so if the doctor died he
would just regenerate but would that
mean that we see this goes to the doctor
and then we see a regenerated doctor
walking around - and I know regeneration
in the last episode was a big point of
contention - like did Davros siphon off
enough regeneration energy that it
burned one of the doctors lives my
inclination is to think that yeah Davros
pretty much burned off one of his
existing lives but remember when Matt
Smith regenerated he got a whole new
cycle so he has plenty of energy to burn
so a lot of things to mull over before
next week's episode in related TV news
lot lots of huge stuff happening in the
next week so we have a Walking Dead
finale tomorrow or fear The Walking Dead
then flash and arrow come back next week
agents of shield is back so be sure to
follow me on Twitter and Facebook for
everything you can always go to my
channel page and look at like my videos
tab to see what I've been posting but
there's a lot of really awesome TV
coming back this week well you guys wait
for everything you can click here to
learn all about the Doctor Who spin-off
class that's I guess coming at the end
of next year there was a little
confusion as to whether it's coming 2016
or 2017 and you can click here to watch
all my arrow and flash trailer videos
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five and I'll see you guys
tonight